can you name three countries outside the
USA uh I could try maybe if my brain
works Africa Africa Asia Costa Rica Asia
Asia Asia Asia Europe what state did the
Boston Tea Party take place
Boston wow Boston Massachusetts [__] oh
[__] I'm [__] United States is
getting 7% more stupider every year
according to New York Times meaning in
22 years the average high school
graduate is expected to be as smart as a
current fifth grader I definitely didn't
make that all but what are your thoughts
on Richard Nixon running against Trump
in the 2024 election Richard Nixon isn't
he dead no seriously though nowadays it
seems like everyone is losing brain
cells by the second what are your
thoughts I don't really have much
thoughts I had to put my theories to the
test I made a list of seven questions a
first grader should be able to answer
let's start with the college bimbos
would you guys consider yourself smart
consider myself what smart yeah smart
smart smart yeah can you name three
countries outside the
USA
Canada Mexico and Russia okay wow so you
guys are pretty smart Antarctica how
much do you guys pay a year for college
zero our daddy does that not us I
dropped out after two months you dropped
out okay your daddy or real daddy real
daddy name three countries outside the
USA I'm from Louisiana Tech I'm not from
here
but Asia Europe
Mexico China
got it Canada wow that was impressive
Brazil Argentina Argentina South America
Italy okay you guys are too smart when
was the US founded like no [__] it's 70
something 1976 yeah know you guys are
too smart for this 17 not 1942 19 and 67
no 1844 1967 and 1844 one of those is
Right 1844 1492 1492 175
no
1774 I don't know colum 1492 it's 1592
are you serious mixed up yeah yeah
1774 1742 1742 you guys are smart not a
lot of people are getting these right
just guess when the the US was founded
1847 us was founded on 1986 198 1967 I
was closer yeah she was close when was
the War of 1812 wasn't it 1810 was it
1810 love it I love she's smart she's
smart
1812 that's the first one you got
wrong I'm not good at it was in 1813
what's 3 * 3 * 3 * 3 * 3 3 * 3 is 9 9 *
3 is what 27 you guys are on it you guys
are like not trying to [__] up right now
n 27 * 3 is 9 9 * 3 is 27
36 what's state did the Boston Tea Party
take place Boston what state
Delaware
Delaware is it not I think it's
Massachusetts massachus okay she's the
smart one enough asking easy questions
the kids paying $50,000 a year for I
don't know what we need to see if the
whole country is this stupid so let's
head over
to Time Square New York City time to
test the people can you name three
countries outside the USA three
countries outside the USA y countries
Africa Paris uh Canada
Bangladesh um turkey turkey okay I would
say uh Fiji Fiji Fiji that's a f ass
country China uh Czech Republic and
Italy Italy okay very good very good
Asia
Asia Argentino okay good what's 3 * 3 *
16 18 18 yeah 13
13 it's a quarter of an hour a quarter
of an hour a quarter 2 25 25 minutes a
quarter of an hour is 25 cents of an
hour oh that's uh 15 minutes 15 minutes
yeah all right you yeah he's good he's
good a quarter of an hour quarter of 20
minutes 20 minutes yeah are you were you
good at math growing up no what were you
good at um English English that's pretty
good hey yeah what state did the Boston
Tea Party take place in Boston Boston
Boston Boston Boston okay people got
these wrong can you believe people got
these wrong when was the US founded what
year 14 something 14 something I don't a
little off a little off
close 1876 Circa close awesome awesome
all right well that was that was
probably one of the better ones to night
oh really I swear yeah a lot of people
got you know almost all those wrong you
you were did pretty good though all
right my YouTube's called Fast growth
yell fast growth fast growth fast
grow